hello good evening the head of the
London fire brigade has promised a major
overhaul of the organization after an
independent report found it to be
institutionally racist and misogynistic
the reports exposed a toxic culture in
the service with lurid examples of
sexism racism and bullying
or speaking to Sky News Today the
commissioner of the UK's biggest fire
brigade apologized we've also heard from
firefighters who are skeptical about the
promises of change a warning that Martin
Brown's report includes one former
firefighter describing the racist abuse
that was directed at him which some
people may find offensive
firefighter Gareth Dawes suffered racism
in different forms sometimes direct
there was an argument that occurred and
I went into the argument and I was
called the black
in that moment
by a colleague by a colleague a serving
colleague from a different watch
and um
the onus was put on me
as to whether I wanted to do anything
about it when we returned station when
he offered to help tackle racism his
bosses encouraged him he said but they
simply didn't understand the problem he
resigned they were just saying that it
wasn't racism this isn't racism so
that's why I mapped it out and said this
is this is how we play it doesn't
necessarily have to be like the n-word
to not for it to be racism
but they just couldn't they just didn't
want to see it they did not want to see
how they were part of the problem it was
denial it was denial it was absolute
denial and it was much easier for them
to see me as a troublemaker and someone
who's too big for their boots the review
was ordered after the suicide of young
firefighter Jaden Francois espri his
family said he was bullied because of
his race
the review of the brigade's culture
condemned it for racism and misogyny
women firefighters told investigators of
being sexually taunted and receiving
video calls of men exposing their
genitalia getting punched slapped and
groped and having uniforms urinated on
CE said the threshold for bullying is so
high you would have to gouge someone's
eyes out to get sacked everything else
is seen as banter
I think I have to apologize to London
and londoners and I have to apologize to
those 2 000 people who raise their voice
that that clearly we have not addressed
this uh issue with the energy we needed
to in the past and where we find people
have not met the standards of behavior
we clearly expect in a zero tolerance
culture to this stuff we will dismiss
them
the report's author said he was sure
there were similar issues in all fire
brigades and Beyond over the last 12
hours are being approached by very
senior figures in the BBC uh various
senior figures in the National Health
Service and also in five different
police forces
um and all of them have said Nazir how
do we get us looked at these behaviors
they're they're embedded in our society
and therefore they'll be embedded in our
institutions
concerns over the Brigade culture aren't
new previous Watchdog inspections had
warned of toxic elements
London's mayor Sadiq Khan said the
details of the report were abhorrent but
he was confident reform would happen the
far Brigade Union said it was skeptical
that senior officers could change their
own behavior the London fire brigade was
already having to reform after claims of
systemic failings in response to the
grenfell tower fire
changing its culture will be a much
bigger demand
Martin brunt Sky News